i was
spelled on by a
white man walking toward me who also
made some racial and sexual comments
vancouver's trixie ling says she was
assaulted in may of 2020 because she is
an asian woman become the model minority
but yet we have this illusion of
belonging but really at the end we are
still very uttered
according to new data released by
statistics canada the number of hate
crimes reported to police in this
country increased sharply in 2020 the
first year of the pandemic to the most
ever recorded hate crimes against black
canadians nearly doubled while those
against east and southeast asian
canadians quadrupled that only counts
cases where victims came forward i think
that the
pandemic has exacerbated
the whole phenomenon last year in
montreal this man made a threatening
gesture at an asian woman he was later
arrested this person was caught on video
verbally abusing an asian man at a
quebec grocery store earlier this year
because of you chinese people not
surprising hate crimes have been on the
rise for years this as overall crime
rates went down 10 percent it is a
national issue almost all provinces saw
hate crime numbers rise stats canada
says the biggest increases were in nova
scotia british columbia saskatchewan and
ontario 84 percent of reported hate
crimes take place in cities
the actual rate of hate crimes in canada
is far higher but
the vast majority of them don't get
reported to police lack of trust in
police and community language barriers
are just a few of the reasons more
people don't come forward trixie ling
did report her incident to police no
arrests were made but she wants to
encourage others to speak up the
anti-asian hate continues because
systemic racism continues so that's why
it's important for us to continue
speaking out a spokesperson for the
public safety minister called the spike
in reported hate crimes alarming and
said a new national action plan for
combating hate is in the works it will
include de-radicalization strategies and
new tools and training for police dan
specter global news ottawa